and then all of a sudden it all hit me
and I was like oh my god Ellen DeGeneres
is bored just like us the TV host is
social distancing herself after the
corona virus outbreak but girl is
struggling same Ellen same but lucky for
her Ellen has some famous friends on
speed dial Justin
yep that's bored Ellen on Instagram leg
up and all calling bored Justin
Timberlake what you doing and turns out
Jessica Biel was doing nothing - what
are you doing next up Ellen calls Adam
Levine to wish him a happy birthday
happy birthday what are you doing not
not much just wait to call and say hey
so happy birthday yeah the comedian
lounges back on the couch both legs up
this time and checks in with Chrissy
Teigen and John Legend Ellen is so bored
she admits she wishes she had kids to
play with so you have kids that we had
kids right now I'm so bored
krisi reposted the Instagram video with
the caption ellen does honestly not know
how to not work
ellen thought about other ways to pass
the time like magic
i'm gonna pick a card i'm gonna call it
out and then i'm gonna just find it okay
four of hearts it quickly became a fail
six of hearts is pretty close I'm gonna
try it two more times
four of hearts six of diamonds one more
time four of hearts all right try to
figure something out it's not working
but count on magician David Blaine to
teach her how it's done just take it
like this look see when you shake it
will just change and become your car
Ellen then tried to complete a four
thousand piece puzzle that turned into a
five-part saga on Instagram I set out to
do something I finish it that's who I am
on the kind of person who says I'm gonna
do something I do it but I counted the
puzzles and the pieces there's only
three thousand nine hundred and
ninety-nine there's not four thousand
pieces plot twist
she miraculously found the missing piece
I find the piece and the piece that's
missing underneath the tangle but still
struggled to turn all the pieces face up
the hardest part is turning each and
every one of these pieces over this is
time-consuming and if you thought the
journey was over
it is Ellen decided to abandon the
puzzle what I realize is
four thousand pieces is ridiculous I
don't have a table big enough who does I
mean whoever gave us this puzzle and I'm
gonna find out who this is ridiculous
but if all else fails hit the gym this
is what you do when you're home then you
have nothing to do you work out if you
get in the gym and then you look at TV
show Ellen decided to go meta and watch
herself on TV
and then I'm here this is a good show
[Music]